[Musique]
et voilà c'était entendez-vous dans nos
campagnes un formidable film Dylan
Teboul bonjour vous êtes le réalisateur
de ce film vous nous faites l'honneur de
participer à Z la Zone d'Éducation
documentaire et juste à vos côtés on
accueille Christine Cloarec le nabourg
bonjour bonjour vous êtes députés la
République en marche dit les vilaine
mais vous êtes sur tout la présidence
d'une mission locale celle du Pays de
Vitré en Bretagne merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation enfin surtout
l'invitation de la seconde 12 du lycée
Eugène Delacroix bonjour les élèves
je sais que vous avez beaucoup beaucoup
travaillé sur ce film avec votre
professeur d'histoire-géo vous avez
plein de questions à poser à nos invités
c'est super mais juste avant j'aimerais
tout simplement connaître un peu votre
point de vue votre sentiment qu'est-ce
qui vous a plu qu'est-ce qui vous a
déplu qu'est-ce qui vous a marqué oui
une histoire qui m'a particulièrement
ému c'était la jeune fille avec son
cheval qui avait l'air émotionnellement
avec lui enfin c'est je trouvais ça
super qu'elle puisse trouver un travail
et en même temps conserver le cheval
elle avait des dettes je crois de
vétérinaires absolument est-ce que vous
avez l'habitude de regarder des
documentaires
non pas trop oui dis-moi Louise
je regarde pas trop de documentaires
mais franchement j'ai bien aimé parce
que on voyait des jeunes un peu et du
coup bah ça nous rapproche un peu plus
parce que il y a pas trop de différence
d'âge entre eux qui entre 18 et 25 ans
on va dire et nous qui sommes au début
de lycée
un peu l'image de jeunes comme nous on
peut
c'était cool est-ce que en regardant ce
film il vous est arrivé de vous dire ça
pourrait être moi
je te vois faire oui dis oui parce que
forcément si ça se trouve ce sera notre
cas quand on aura l'orage et que on
passera forcément dans ce dans ce
passage de l'orientation qu'est-ce qu'on
va devoir faire et peut-être certains
d'entre nous vont besoin de cette
garantie jeune d'une mission locale et
ça fait bien ça fait du bien de savoir
que ça existe alors justement tu me fais
un lien parfait pour la prochaine
question qui connaissait l'existence des
missions locales lever la main ce qui
connaissait déjà l'existence de mission
locale
c'est pas beaucoup alors on va passer on
va passer à vos questions Victor
pourquoi avoir choisi de travailler en
particulier sur la mission de bocal de
Molen
c'est vraiment le hasard qui m'a amené
là au départ je venais pour autre chose
j'écrivais une fiction donc pas du tout
un documentaire je suis documentariste
et j'avais besoin de rencontrer des
jeunes qui vivent un peu loin des villes
dans un endroit qui ressemble pas
vraiment à la campagne qui pourtant et
la campagne je me suis retrouvé en
Alsace dans la vallée de la Bruche à
Molsheim qui est au pied de la Bruche et
on m'a proposé d'assister à une un
atelier collectif d'un garantie jeune
qui commençait
et en assistant à ça je suis passionné
pour ce qui se passait là devant moi et
la fiction elle était place au
documentaire et à la réalité Robin tu
avais une question pour madame la
députée comment sont répartis les
missions locales sur les territoires
français on a alors 436 missions locales
mais surtout les missions locales elles
ont un siège mais elles ont plusieurs
points d'accueil sur les territoires
tant et si bien qu'il y a effectivement
plus de 7000 points d'accueil des
missions locales partout en France et en
outre-mer et ensuite on a des
associations régionales qui animent le
réseau sur les territoires et ensuite on
a unml l'Union nationale des missions
locales tout en haut c'est une
association qui fait partie du service
public de l'emploi comme pôle emploi
donc ils ont on a une mission de service
public dans l'accompagnement des jeunes
vers l'autonomie et l'insertion
professionnel Dana dans la garantie
jeune comment se fait le travail en
équipe entre les différents acteurs et
actrices qui accompagnent les jeunes
comme les assistantes sociales et
l'éducateurs spécialisés etc il y a pas
une multiplicité d'acteurs donc on fait
avec les acteurs qui sont là et puis
après c'est une volonté de collaborer
toujours au service du jeûne c'est à
dire qu'un jeune il arrive il a pas
seulement des problèmes d'orientation et
de d'insertion professionnelle il peut
avoir aussi des soucis de logement des
soucis de mobilité des soucis de santé
des soucis d'accès aux droits il
n'arrive pas à faire ses démarches tout
seul etc c'est vraiment un
accompagnement qu'on appelle global et
ça c'est toutes les missions locales en
réalisant ce documentaire est-ce que
votre idée c'était plutôt de montrer aux
jeunes qui habitent dans les honneurs
rurales qui avaient des solutions pour
eux ou plutôt pour nous jeunes de la
ville nous montrer leur réalité leurs
problèmes c'est un peu des deux c'est
vrai que eux au départ on va parler
d'eux aussi un peu bien sûr eux au
départ déjà avaient du mal à comprendre
pourquoi quelqu'un de la capitale avec
une caméra venue s'intéresser à eux déjà
ça c'était quelque chose qui était assez
très curieux pour eux et on est
rapidement entré dans une relation
ensemble ils avaient envie que je sois
là et à la fois il ne comprenait pas
pourquoi j'étais là qu'est-ce qu'il y a
d'intéressant à nous filmer nous donc ça
déjà moi ça m'a tout de suite touché et
je me suis dit il faut que je creuse là
ensuite je pense qu'à partir du moment
où on regarde l'autre
vivre exister que ce soit un jeune que
ce soit un adulte peu importe c'est la
question même du documentaire et ben
c'est
c'est prendre conscience de l'autre
c'est exercer son altérité se dire bah
en fait on est tous les mêmes et il
avait une réalité qui est différente de
la mienne mais sa réalité elle me touche
et donc ben je sais je peux le regarder
et m'intéresser à lui voilà est-ce que
l'idée oui clairement clairement
c'est peut-être aussi pour ça que le
film s'appelle entendez-vous dans nos
campagnes c'est alors que c'était une
manière pour moi de rendre à ses
invisibles de réintégrer ces invisibles
dans le récit national quand allez-vous
dans le campagne voilà c'est la
Marseillaise et clairement
les jeunes que j'ai rencontrés ils ont
un sentiment d'exclusion qui est elle
qui ont ils m'ont pas donné les
sentiments voilà de d'avoir conscience
qu'ils appartenaient à la même nation
que moi
est-ce que le choix du titre a été comme
une évidence pour vous c'était aussi un
clin d'oeil parce que en tant que dans
vos campagnes il y a le mot de campagne
dedans et là où j'étais ça ressemblait
pas à la campagne que j'avais dans la
tête au départ il y avait pas de vache
il y a pas de pâturage c'est des vallées
des vallons c'est des forêts de
conifères c'est des petits villages qui
sont enclavés il y a pas de point de vue
quand on pense campagne on se dit ben la
campagne c'est les territoires voilà
exactement il y a pas d'horizon et tout
ça a participé
en tout cas ce que je comprenne un peu
mieux la manière voilà que eux avaient
de voir le monde
en choisissant les plans larges pour
pour montrer les les paysages de la
Vallée de la Bruche et bien insister sur
l'enclavement de la ville mais au
contraire à l'intérieur de la Mission
Locale privilégiez les plans rapprochés
sur les têtes des personnes etc quels
étaient l'effet recherché quand je fais
un film je suis guidé par des intentions
qui sont souvent spontanées
donc quand je vais filmer des humains je
vais avoir tendance à me rapprocher
d'eux
ce qui m'intéresse c'est qu'on voit il y
a des moments je suis très très serré
c'est moi qui filme tout le temps il y a
pas d'autres caméras les personnes ne
fume d'autres il y a que moi et je sais
que plus j'entre dans une relation avec
eux plus j'ai tendance à m'approcher si
je pouvais entrer dans leur tête je le
ferai les grands espaces en effet c'est
le territoire dans lequel ils vivent
je les trouve assez beau ces espaces là
et finalement ils sont très beaux et ce
sont des espaces qui les entravent et
que eux-mêmes ont un peu du mal aussi
avoir comme de beaux espaces certains
sont fiers de la plupart sont fiers de
là où ils habitent mais ils se sentent
enfermés ils sont en prison dans ces
grands espaces et être en prison dans un
grand espace c'est quelque chose qui m'a
intéressé et justement est-ce que est-ce
que vous les zones rurales ça vous parle
vous en connaissez enfin ce que vous
avez découvert un milieu en regardant ce
documentaire oui Louise en vrai moi je
pensais font les jeunes de la campagne
ils se décident ils se dessinaient plus
à l'agriculture ou à la ferme et je
pensais pas qu'ils avaient autant
d'objectifs et qu'il cherchait avoir
aussi loin que qu'en ville par exemple
comme là aussi je pensais que c'était
centré sur l'agriculture mais je pensais
aussi que les jeunes vaillent leur
métier était un peu prédéterminé vous
allez suivre la voie de leurs parents
donc dans leur ferme et des choses comme
ça
moi aussi bah en fait je pensais que je
pensais pas que la campagne c'était
comme ça je pensais que nos parents bah
ils étaient toujours habillés en
combinaison pour traire les vaches et
que voilà il y avait que des champs il y
avait rien des maisonnettes
de ce que c'est que le milieu rural ça
peut être ça mais c'est pas tout le
temps ça je suis né dans le 93 il y a
longtemps maintenant et en 79 je suis
venue en Bretagne parce que mes parents
étaient originaires de Bretagne et alors
mes mes amis en fait me disaient mais tu
vas vivre en sabot
elle m'avait acheté vous savez le truc
qui fait me quand on retourne la boîte
etc il y avait déjà en fait cette image
de la campagne qui n'est pas vraiment ça
Elena oui pensez-vous en fait qu'il y a
un cercle vicieux dans ces espaces
enclavés ou de plus en plus de services
publics ou de service de proximité ferme
où il y a des déserts médicaux ou en
fait tous les jeunes partent de ces
espaces pour aller trouver un emploi
dans des autres villes et donc
pensez-vous que tous ces tous ces effets
soient du coup un cercle vicieux le
basculement chez les jeunes il se fait
au moment de partir de partir faire
leurs études
à 18 ans parce que bah dans les
campagnes il n'y a pas d'établissement
d'enseignement supérieur déjà et même
les CFA sont pas forcément les centres
de formation ne sont pas sur les dans
les territoires ruraux ou très peu et
donc il faut faire beaucoup de
kilomètres alors si vous êtes dans
milieu rural et que vous avez une voix
de chemin de fer c'est bien c'est plutôt
facile si vous êtes dans une petite
commune où il y a pas du tout de de
lignes de chemin de fer près il y a pas
de bus il y a rien vous êtes
complètement isolé et dans le
documentaire on le voit très bien c'est
un sujet la mobilité et ça c'est pas
spécifique que dans le rural c'est à
dire que il y a des jeunes qui
n'envisagent pas d'aller au-delà de leur
quartier
ou au-delà de leur commune et donc il y
a tout un travail c'est tout tout le
travail des conseillers en insertion
mission locale c'est de débloquer tout
ça et de
co-construire le parcours avec le jeûne
les frontières sont celles qu'on se fixe
soi-même voilà c'est vraiment ce que
j'ai ressenti c'est à dire que en effet
il ne s'autorise pas à même si c'est
vrai que c'est difficile pour eux aller
faire des études un peu plus loin il
faut que les parents puissent nous loger
il faut enfin c'est tout un voilà c'est
tout plein de choses auxquelles ils
n'ont pas nécessairement accès comment
ces jeunes qui habitent dans des villes
peurs
urbanisées loin des grandes métropoles
bah ils peuvent ils peuvent être
informés qu'il y a des missions locales
parfois dans leur ville ou à côté est-ce
que c'est vous qui allez faire toc toc
il y a une mission locale vient ça peut
t'aider souvent ce sont les parents les
amis ou très souvent Pôle Emploi aussi
qui oriente vers la mission locale et
quand ils viennent pas il faut aller les
chercher et comment on peut aller les
chercher bah c'est simplement pour de
travailler avec les associations
sportives
avec les associations culturales avec
les élus pour rebondir sur la question
de Riad ce sont des jeunes qui sont
isolés dans l'espace et dans la société
mais est-ce que il serait pas aussi
connecté à nous grâce au réseau sociaux
et donc par là il pourrait se joindre
mission locale c'est un travail que vous
ouais
après je peux pas parler pour toutes les
missions locales de France mais dans la
mienne en tous les cas on a investi les
réseaux sociaux on est sur on est sur
comment Instagram on est sur même sur
Tik Tok enfin etc et en fait on essaye
de toucher les jeunes avec
des vidéos par exemple c'est tout bête
mais ça parle plus avec des avec des
témoignages de jeunes qui ont fait par
exemple des parcours d'apprentissage qui
sont allés en garantie jeunes qui ont
fait des services civiques etc et depuis
que nous avons fait ça en fait nous
arrivons à toucher beaucoup plus de
jeunes des jeunes qui en parlent en plus
à leur copains et copines qui peuvent
avoir besoin d'un accompagnement on peut
peut-être appeler que l'émission locale
elles existent depuis 40 ans au départ
c'était un accompagnement plutôt en face
à face avec le conseiller et que ce qui
a changé avec la garantie jeune c'est
que on a mis ce collectif collectif
d'émulation qui crée de la
remobilisation chez les jeunes et
pendant ces quatre à six semaines on
propose tout un tas d'activités il y a
des certifications il y a le travail sur
la confiance en soi on fait appel des
fois des acteurs pour venir justement
travailler des comédiens pour travailler
ce sujet là
il y a le travail sur la recherche
d'emploi enfin voilà il y a tout un tas
d'ateliers qu'on propose c'est de phase
collective elle permet aussi aux jeunes
et bien de voir qui ne sont pas seuls à
vivre des parcours compliqués et ça
c'est important c'est ce qui a fait la
réussite de cette garantie jeune Meriem
tu avais une question je voulais savoir
s'il existe d'autres dispositifs pour
aider accompagner les jeunes en
difficulté isolées à part l'émission
locale vous avez tout un tas de
d'accompagnants et après derrière il y a
tout un tas de dispositifs on parle de
la garantie jeune mais il y a les jeunes
qu'on met en alternance on apprentissage
puis plus tard en contrat de
professionnalisation pour certains et
donc bah là le principal c'est que le
conseiller en insertion que vous allez
voir peu importe dans quelle structure
il soit en capacité de vous orienter par
rapport à un diagnostic par rapport à
qui vous êtes ce que vous avez envie de
faire ce qui est possible etc Louis pour
compléter justement
comme les éducateurs et les conseillers
d'orientation qui intervenaient ils vont
t-il à titre de salarié ou sont-ils
bénévoles justement alors dans
l'émission locale alors dans l'émission
locale il y a les conseillers en
insertion qui sont salariés et puis
après il y a des gens qui viennent
ponctuellement
c'est pas le corps qui vous contrôle
c'est vous qui devez contrôler le corps
[Musique]
l'intérieur
est beaucoup plus puissant que
l'extérieur
c'est bien qu'on parle de conseiller
qu'on parle d'autres langues aussi qu'on
voit dans le dans le film qui est ce
prof de kung-fu qui leur apprend à
méditer je vous avoue que moi-même
j'étais très surpris de rencontrer de
Chang dans un lieu comme ça et qui voilà
qui a compris que clairement ce sont des
jeunes ou qui vont pas bien à
l'intérieur et donc lui il leur dit
juste ben voilà on va essayer de
reconnecter ton corps et ton esprit il
le fait bien il le fait très bien et
leur parle de quelque chose qui est très
important je me permets d'insister qui
est très important qui sont les rêves et
ça on en a pas parlé depuis tout à
l'heure vous avez posé tout plein de
questions mais clairement quand on a 18
ans 19 ans qu'on est aux arrêts qu'on ne
sait pas ce qu'on va faire de sa vie on
a des angoisses terribles et pourtant on
a quand même des rêves et que des
adultes
s'intéresse aux rêves que l'on a ben moi
j'ai trouvé ça très touchant et je sais
que eux aussi donc il faut voilà déjà
retrouver l'estime de soi
d'ailleurs ça peut aider en fait il y en
avait pas énormément mais en fait depuis
un moment on a vu arriver de plus en
plus de jeunes en souffrance psychique
et donc on a aujourd'hui des
psychologues il y a aussi des des points
accueil écoute jeunes qui existent sur
le territoire quelquefois ce sont les
missions locales qui portent mais
quelquefois ce sont d'autres structures
mais après dans chaque mission locale
aujourd'hui vous avez des psychologues
qui sont là pour les jeunes et qui sont
là aussi pour les conseiller d'ailleurs
est-ce que ça vous arrive parfois de
d'intervenir dans des lycées pour en
parler avec tout à fait je me déplace
dès l'école primaire d'ailleurs mais
aussi au collège et au lycée pour
échanger sur la mission de députés et
tout un tas de
le sujet est-ce que parfois vous êtes
reconnu à travers un personnage un
regard une réponse je me suis pas
reconnue personnellement personnellement
mais surtout dans la partie du
décrochage scolaire enfin c'est un sujet
qui nous a touché beaucoup tous surtout
en fin d'année 4e 3e avec le confinement
etc donc toutes ces parties voilà qui
parlaient aussi de la santé mentale et
du décrochage scolaire je pense que
c'est un sujet qui a touché la plupart
de nos camarades pendant ces années donc
c'est un sujet voilà qui nous a tous
touché je pense vous voyez tout ce qui
est le personnage de Dorian Dorian vous
l'avez
j'ai pas envie de parler de moi
j'ai pas envie d'exploser ma vie et mes
problèmes à tout le monde quand j'étais
plus jeune à l'école j'étais souvent
tapé on me discriminait on me rabaissait
du coup moi résultat je restais dans mon
coin et je parlais à personne et je
faisais rien j'étais toujours dans mon
coin
alors c'est bizarre à dire mais je vais
vous le dire quand même je me suis vu en
Dorian alors pas maintenant mais il y a
20 ans alors pas dans la même situation
pas dans les mêmes pas voilà pas dans le
même environnement évidemment mais cette
incapacité parfois à tout simplement
s'exprimer le fait de se mettre un petit
peu en retrait avec son écouteur parce
que parce qu'on n'arrive pas finalement
c'est pas une volonté c'est c'est juste
qu'on n'y arrive pas moi ça m'a parlé
est-ce que personne là dans la classe
c'est dit on a tous un petit peu de
Dorian en nous ou en tout cas oui oui
dis-moi bah il y a eu avant avant la
quatrième
j'étais assez timide je me refermais
beaucoup dans une bulle où je restais
dans mon monde et là bah ça m'a fait ça
m'a fait penser à ça
même sans être évidemment complètement
le même personnage mais en fait
j'ai reconnu plusieurs personnes avec
qui j'ai pu être en contact durant ma
scolarité OK et cette personne qui est
au fond de la salle casquette ses qui
veut rien écouter qui qui s'intéresse
pas
que ce soit le cas en fait Dorian c'est
en effet le gars du fond de la classe
avec sa casquette et ses écouteurs
le personnage comme ça qui paraît
totalement c'est très compliqué de
parler avec lui on a l'impression qu'il
comprend rien que de manière et c'est
une des personnes les plus intelligentes
que j'ai rencontré dans ma vie
clairement c'était voilà c'est c'est
vous là vous l'entendez penser à mon
l'entend réfléchir et les mots d'Orient
sont très précis il sait exactement ce
qu'il fait il sait exactement ce qu'il
pense il connaît aussi l'origine oui de
son mal-être absolument et en fait on
parle souvent de décrochage de
problématiques d'orientation on sait pas
ce qu'on va devenir alors que on nous
demande exactement de choisir maintenant
là il faut choisir où on va ce qu'on
fait bon ça c'est le point de vue très
très aérien qui fait qu'on est tous les
mêmes voilà
et puis après il y a nos histoires nos
histoires de vie et ces endroits où
parfois
on va prendre des coups on va rien dire
et on va essayer de les oublier et on va
avancer en disant que ça va aller et
puis à un moment donné on sait plus
avancé on n'arrive plus à regarder
devant soi on est embrumé on voit plus
rien et c'est ce qui se passe pour la
plupart de ces jeunes et j'ai envie de
dire pour la plupart d'entre nous
voit dans le documentaire que vous avez
réussi à faire parler de certains jeunes
de leur situation précarité ou des
violences qui sont subies
discriminations ou autre mais comment
est-ce que vous avez pu réussir à leur
faire parler de ça sachant qu'ils sont
face à un groupe et que c'est pas
forcément facile d'en parler assez
rapidement
je j'ai eu à filmer une séquence dans
laquelle ils ont à raconter chacun leur
tour devant la classe enfin devant
justement pas la classe devant le groupe
ils ont raconté une expérience
surprenante quelque chose qu'ils ont
vécu qui les a fortement marqués et puis
plus on avance plus l'histoire qui est
racontée est intime et moi je suis en
train de filmer à ce moment-là ils sont
tous en train de raconter des choses qui
sont assez fortes de leur vie
et pour être très franc j'étais
tellement
impacté parce que quand on filme on
ressent toute l'émotion c'est vraiment
enfin moi je la prends en pleine tête
comme ça et clairement je me suis dit si
je veux être honnête je pose ma caméra
moi aussi je vais prendre un petit
papier une petite photo je la pose au
mur et je vais raconter moi aussi
quelque chose qui m'est arrivé et qui
m'a marqué et j'ai clairement senti à ce
moment-là que quelque chose se crée
entre eux et moi s'attendais pas du tout
à ce que moi je me prête aussi au jeu et
que je sois dégâts égal avec eux et je
pense que c'est ça qui compte c'est
d'être légal égal avec quelqu'un tout
simplement donc j'ai créé une relation
de confiance avec eux je leur ai donné
des choses je leur ai dit des choses de
ma vie hors caméra aussi enfin beaucoup
surtout on a beaucoup échangé et puis au
fil de l'eau et ben
[Musique]
voilà ils m'ont fait confiance
au tout début du film est-ce que vous
savez ce qu'est une mission
et qu'est-ce qu'on y trouve c'est des
cours mais des cours pour apprendre le
monde du travail et moi je connais rien
sur le monde du travail est-ce que à
votre avis il faudrait plus de cours
pour apprendre le monde du travail dans
un lycée au lycée par exemple oui Thomas
à mon avis oui il en faudrait parce que
par exemple c'est pas l'école qu'on va
apprendre à payer nos impôts des choses
comme ça c'est le rôle des parents mais
c'est pas forcément tout le monde qui a
des parents qui sont présents pour les
accompagner vous êtes tous inégaux
ça devrait changer alors le monde du
travail c'est pas que les impôts
je plaisante mais vous avez tous réalisé
un stage de 3e
non pas forcément d'accord est-ce que
est-ce que ça a été facile de trouver un
stage d'observation Elena pas du tout
parce que moi dans mon cas j'ai dû
envoyer je ne sais combien de mails à
plein d'agences différentes plein
d'entreprises différentes priant
vraiment pour qu'elle me répondent avec
des formules de politesse un CV une
lettre de motivation enfin c'était très
compliqué et j'ai bien mis trois quatre
semaines à trouver un stage si je vous
dis
je traverse la rue et je vous trouve un
travail elle vous parle cette phrase
exactement c'est le président de la
République qui a qui a dit ça le 15
septembre 2018 qu'est-ce que ça t'évoque
la phrase elle est trop belle c'est pas
la réalité quelqu'un qui veut trouver du
travail bah c'est pas comme il est il va
il traverse la rue il trouve mon jour je
veux un travail ok d'accord ça se passe
pas comme ça
que je trouve les des documentaires
comme celui qu'on vient de voir ils sont
très bienvenus du coup parce que ils
nous montrent la vraie réalité et c'est
mieux que ces belles paroles d'autres
veulent réagir à cette phrase du
président Emmanuel Macron oui
clairement que bah en traversant il
trouve du travail sauf que il y a des
patrons qui demandent des
des diplômes que tout le monde n'a pas
forcément qui demande des des
antécédents entre guillemets dans le
monde du travail que des jeunes n'ont
pas parce que c'est pas facile de
trouver du travail donc c'est sa phrase
elle est fausse alors c'est une phrase
qui commence à dater il faut la remettre
dans le contexte c'était un jeune qui
était paysagiste en fait qui était dans
et qui voulait absolument travailler
dans une collectivité et donc c'est vrai
que on savait que dans le dans le
secteur de des paysagistes ils cherchait
de la main d'oeuvre donc il faut voilà
faut recadrer ça ceci dit
elle est quand même malvenue cette
phrase non mais certainement mais tout
ce que je veux dire c'est que vous en
avez très bien parlé c'est que on parle
souvent de l'employabilité des jeunes et
on parlera rarement de l'employeur
habilité des entreprises et ça commence
à venir parce que les entreprises
aujourd'hui elles cherchent de la main
d'oeuvre et il faut absolument que les
entreprises s'adaptent s'adaptent il a
une convoitent pour certains soit jamais
jamais connu le monde du travail donc
ils ont peur soit on déjà eu une ou deux
expériences avec des patrons les termes
qui étaient toujours employés le patron
le patron voilà on les entend au tout
début de leur expérience qui sont pas
très positives non pas positif du tout
parce qu'ils ont le sentiment qu'on ne
les accepte pas enfin qui sont là pour
apprendre déjà que les métiers les
connaissent pas toujours et qu'on leur
fait payer le fait de pas connaître le
métier donc c'est compliqué et souvent
ils sont carrément traumatisés par la
première expérience en tout cas il reste
un peu des enfants et le patron c'est le
monde des adultes le monde des parents
et il se met en rupture avec ça je
voulais vous demander est-ce que vous
vous auriez participé est-ce que vous
vous auriez participé à documentaire ou
en tout cas un documentaire comme ça
vous sentiriez capable de vous livrer
comme ça sur vos envies vos rêves Thomas
moi franchement en soi si c'est pour
trouver de l'aide et du travail j'aurais
participé mais après pour divulguer en
particulier mais partager ma vie ça
aurait été un peu plus compliqué parce
que faut avoir une certaine un certain
courage pour pouvoir partager des
moments durs ou bien des conditions
dures qu'on vit
bon en fait tout dépend de la personne à
qui on va se livrer si elle nous met à
l'aise et qu'elle qu'on se sent bien bah
là à partir de ce moment-là on peut on
peut tout dire
tu as une question
victimes de discrimination par exemple
sur le fait d'être voilé ou d'être une
fille et non un garçon est-ce que vous
pensez qu'ils en sont conscients
j'aimerais me voiler et c'est ma
décision mon père me force pas personne
me force une femme qui porte le voile
musulmane et les discriminer c'est
toujours trouver du boulot maintenant
déjà on en trouve pas qu'on n'est pas
voilé mais voilà
encore pire des fois je vais pas mentir
s'ils prennent pas je me dis ouais il
avait mon prénom
c'est paradoxal parce qu'ils ont une
certaine esprit sur le monde qui les
entoure et à la fois ils ont du mal à
comprendre ce monde donc on reparlait
des frontières tout à l'heure donc
typiquement il y a quand même pas mal de
jeunes qui vivent dans des dans des
petits villages on l'a dit et sortir du
village
ne pas avoir ne pas avoir le sentiment
que pour certains il est même question
de handicap on en parle aussi à un
moment donné donc handicap plus ou moins
visible enfin certains ont le sentiment
qu'il est écrit handicap sur leur visage
ou qu'ils aillent ou qu'ils aillent donc
oui dans son conscient et le subisse
aussi de manière plus générale sur les
grandes lignes on traite aussi des
discriminations est-ce que ça fait
partie de vos de vos objectifs
oui bien sûr on traite de l'égalité
femme homme on bien sûr on traite de
toutes les discriminations on travaille
sur la citoyenneté sur la laïcité enfin
tous les termes sont abordés en fait en
mission locale donc après
voilà on essaie de faire parler les
jeunes sur ce qu'ils sur ce qu'il
ressentent il peut y avoir des ateliers
justement sur l'égalité femme homme tout
à fait complètement Agathe
changements dans la vie des jeunes de
l'émission quand tu parles de changement
tu veux
grâce à la garantie jeune etc pour
certains la garantie elle était très
positive on va parler de Sandra oui
Sandra elle a carrément eu son permis
grâce à la garantie jeune elle a pu
payer son permis grâce à la garantie
jeune
donc elle a trouvé un travail on la voit
s'épanouir elle est toute un tout petit
oiseau au début elle nous appelle
prendre la parole et au fil du temps et
puis on la voit totalement se
transformer et carrément être caissier
un supermarché mais pour elle c'est
énorme et d'envisager après de se dire
bah voilà moi j'aimerais faire des
études pour travailler dans l'éclairage
de théâtre ou de spectacle elle
s'autorise à rêver alors que le
personnage du début ne s'autorisait pas
à rêver donc oui on voit carrément une
évolution Célia est-ce que aujourd'hui
on a des retours sur l'impact qu'a eu la
Mission Locale
ça les a aidés après
si tu veux c'est vrai que l'objectif
c'est le retour à l'emploi moi ce que ce
qui m'intéressait c'était pas tant le
retour à l'emploi que le retour à la vie
tout court tu vois donc pour certains
simplement de d'y croire à nouveau et se
dire qu'ils ont une valeur
et te dire que peut-être qu'ils vont
faire une formation par exemple et ben
certains font des formations on le voit
à la fin d'ailleurs on a et donc
l'emploi c'est important la formation
c'est important et juste avoir le goût
de reprendre la vie c'est encore plus
important si si vous aviez un message si
vous les aviez en face de vous tous
aligné là qu'est-ce que vous auriez
envie de leur dire courage
bravo aussi bravo félicitations je sais
pas bravo aussi d'avoir réussi à vous à
reprendre votre vie en main et votre vie
en main pardon et bravo d'avoir réussi à
vous relever malgré d'avoir commencé
dans une situation difficile qu'est-ce
qu'on souhaite à tous les jeunes qui
nous regardent qu'ils soient de banlieue
de campagne de France d'ailleurs
ce qui est important c'est vraiment que
chaque jeune trouve sa place dans la
cité et souvent on parle de formation
d'accès à l'emploi etc moi j'ai envie de
dire que avant ça il faut que le jeûne
se sente citoyen c'est à dire qu'ils se
sentent complètement impliqué dans dans
la vie de la cité vous pouvez aussi
venir en mission locale parce qu'à un
moment donné dans votre parcours vous
allez avoir besoin d'un accompagnement
et donc vous allez vous aurez peut-être
besoin un jour en tous les cas j'espère
que vous serez bien accueilli et que on
pourra vous accompagner le mieux
possible et peut-être même en tant que
bénévole si vous avez envie de
participer aussi d'aider d'autres
d'autres copains copines ou des jeunes
tout simplement qui ont votre âge et
partager votre expérience
bien sûr Ilan teboule pour finir d'avoir
échangé comme ça avec des jeunes qui ont
quasiment le même âge mais qui viennent
d'un autre environnement ça vous
qu'est-ce que ça vous fait moi ça me
touche beaucoup d'être là de parler
avec vous
et ce que vous avez posé des questions
quand même très intéressantes bravo
finalement ce qu'on a tous en commun
c'est
il faut suivre ses rêves on en a parlé
voilà suivre ses rêves et ne pas oublier
que c'est pas la destination qui compte
c'est le chemin donc voilà tant que vous
êtes en chemin vous irez quelque part
après que ce soit là où vous aviez prévu
d'aller ou ailleurs c'est pas grave
c'est parce qu'il compte ce qui compte
c'est d'être en chemin on va on va
terminer l'émission là-dessus merci
infiniment à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ces échanges passionnants
merci beaucoup à votre professeur
d'histoire-géo qui nous a permis
d'organiser justement ce bel échange et
cette émission et puis merci à vous les
élèves de la seconde 12 du lycée de la
Croix vous pouvez vous applaudir
franchement c'était super bravo bravo
pour le pour le travail et puis merci
merci infiniment pour toutes vos
questions tout le tout le travail on se
retrouve évidemment très vite sur les
réseaux sociaux n'hésitez pas à me
suivre sur insta bien sûr et puis Z
revient très vite avec une nouvelle
classe et un nouveau parce qu'il n'y a
pas d'âge pour questionner le monde et
ces images allez salut
[Musique]